they've completed a treble only achieved
once before by an english team they're
great Rivals Manchester United and
Manchester City here in Istanbul by
beating Inter Milan one nil have
completed the set of major trophies in
the 15 years of Abu Dhabi ownership and
ownership that's transformed the club
with billions of wealth and it's
delivered this sporting greatness that
has the fans erupting and celebration in
the atter Turk Stadium this wasn't City
on the pitch at their all-conquering
best but they have conquered Europe for
the first time but it wasn't easy it
took until the 68th minute for City to
find the Breakthrough with Roger scoring
what might be just the most important
goal in the history of the club the
Breakthrough that they needed
celebrations that nearly were cut very
short and only saved
in the minutes after that thanks to the
saves of Edison the City goalkeeper
after hitting the bar
and then a city held on in this final
the second ever final there was Edison
to deny romulo lukaku's header right as
this game was creeping into the 90th
minute and City and Edison
managing to preserve the one nil lead
and celebrations that confirmed city as
Champions League winners for the first
time two years after losing to Chelsea
in their only previous final having won
the FA Cup and the Premier League last
month a complete set of three major
trophies and for Pep Guardiola one of
the greatest managers of all time his
first Champions League title since his
days of Barcelona in 2011 and this on a
night when Manchester City's owner Shake
Mansour attended only a second match in
his 15 years of owner What A Night to
choose for him and even his presence
here remind us of the bigger picture of
this Manchester City's success because
it's about more than a football club
it's effectively the extension of Abu
Dhabi foreign policy winning on the
pitch exerts this soft power and
influence that demonstrates the wealth
and the status of Abu Dhabi But
ultimately for the city fans they've
turned a club that for so long lived in
the shadows of Manchester United without
any their success turned them into now
one of the world's most all-conquering
teams and tonight Manchester City by
beating into Milan have finally won the
Champions League the one prize that
eluded them